this is a production of Cornell
University
[Applause]
okay thanks Adam can everyone hear me
all right okay good so I thank you again
for the for the invitation I've had a
wonderful time with my first time to
this campus and I appreciate you
bringing in the great weather too
because everyone lies about what the
weather normally is like here right so
today I'm going to tell you about a
study in the lab that's a joint effort
by my lab and our neighboring lab shall
yugyeong and this was a little
serendipitous how it occurred but really
this is a joint effort he could be
standing here giving you a very similar
presentation and so this is the work of
a student in his lab bill Ricci who's
developed some of the technologies and
implemented them from use in animals to
plants I'll highlight his contributions
as well as people from my lab as if ulu
helped adopt a taxi for application to
plant genomes to map chromatin
accessibility and then the people in my
lab really led the data analysis and
this work is almost exclusively funded
and supported by the National Science
Foundation and so one of the sort of
long-term goals of our lab it might be a
bit lofty but we really would like to
find ways to induce variation to induce
allelic variation that we can lead to
phenotypic variation that we could sort
of introduce into breeding programs and
there's lots of efforts especially on
this campus where you're using existing
or standing and genetic variation in
those programs but we want to look to
the future and try to adopt these gene
editing technologies in combination with
with what we're studying about what
we're learning about these plant genomes
to sort of accelerate that process and
so I just use this as an example many of
you are part of familiar with this work
there are other people who have done
very similar experiments but this is a
nice example of what can result from
inducing genetic variation at a
non-coding regulatory element so this is
some nice work from Zac Lippman's lab
where they they already knew that this
gene Clamato 3 is important for a whole
range of developmental
traits associated with tomato of a fruit
shape and size and what they did is they
essentially carpet-bombed this
non-coding regulatory region within the
couple KB upstream of the coding
sequence and from that they were able to
create a range of expression variation
and also phenotypic variation associated
with essentially miss expression
expressing this gene or or expressing it
in different cell types possibly or
different levels and so this worked
primarily because the the locus said
they're studying most of the regulatory
variations actually found here within
the sort of the the neighboring to
kilobase region of this locus and that's
actually true for a lot of plant genes
and for those of us I'm guilty of this
that have worked on a rabbit OPS's most
of our careers that's where everything
resides because that's the only place
you can put it but what I'll tell you
today is by using chromatin structure we
can now identify rather acutely these
what we predict our regulatory elements
in any any plant genome so what are
these regulatory elements your sort of
classic textbook definition goes like
this you have a court you have a gene it
has a core promoter where these general
transcription factors assemble and then
you can have these these regulatory
elements that can appear either
downstream or upstream of the gene and
they can occur in any orientation and
that's because in specific cell types
for example here in the limb there's a
limb transcription factor as expressed
and it helps position and create the 3d
conformation that helps provide cell
type-specific expression and you can see
here in this example there are binding
sites for brain transcription factors
but they're occluded by nucleosomes and
of course those transcription factors
aren't present in these lymph cells so
this is one area where I'm a little
envious I see it was quite envious of
people working and studying animal
epigenomes because for a long time now
almost a decade if not longer they have
been able to take these very large
genomes and use sort of functional
epigenomics data and very quickly not
only identify coding sequence and genes
but also identify these likely
regulatory elements using a chromatin
structure and other signatures and and
and so in animals often
what you find at these these these
regions that are found out here these
distal regulatory elements is that there
are there are specific histone
modifications that characterize these
regions they're enriched as you might
expect for transcription factor binding
these regions are have accessible
chromatin that enables transcription
factor binding and part of that is
because there's this rapid nuclear zone
turnover often at these regions now we
could do many of these same experiments
in plants so for example planets also
have h3k4 monomethylation but in plants
this is not found in energetic sequence
it's actually found in gene bodies and
so if we're just you know using this
single histone modification to predict
the location of these elements in plant
genomes it just didn't work but what we
hypothesized and what's expected is that
there should be in Richmond for
transcription factor binding sites and
to enable that these regions should be
have accessible chromatin and so we
worked hard a few years ago to try a
whole range of experiments to adopt this
method referred to as a tack seek for
application to plant genome so this was
developed by will Greenleaf out of
Stanford and and essentially the way
this assay works is if they can profile
regions that essentially proteins can
can access in in chromatin because they
take advantage of a hyperactive
transposes that will integrate DNA
sequences in regions that are accessible
compared to regions like here that are
inaccessible and so after doing that as
a simple PCR reaction that reveals these
accessible regions in the genome and so
you you get these landscapes like you
see here if these Peaks that emerge and
and what they could show quite nicely is
that this method for mapping
accessibility benchmark really well to
sort of standard accepted methodologies
that were out there the time and what
was nice about this particular assay is
that the input for the number of cells
was much lower than was a practice and
we in practice at the time of course now
this method is being used for single
cells right again the challenge was
applying this to plants you know it's
not hard to isolate nuclei many of us do
it all the time it's a simple incubation
with this hyperactive transpose ace and
PCR sequencing and you can do this
repetitively in it spend a lot of money
sequencing a lot of mitochondrial gene
right it's actually if you read a lot of
the papers in the animal literature
you'll find a lot of the sequences are
derived from the mitochondria and of
course this is a of course doesn't have
a typical chromatin state it's highly
accessible as acting as a sink for a lot
of that transpose ace and of course in
plants the mitochondria is about 20
times larger the genome is about 20
times larger than the human
mitochondrial and then there are
chloroplast genomes and they're also
large and there are many chloroplasts
often per cell and so basically in the
lattice of food Lou who who finally got
this to work hypothesized that we just
need to actually a cleaner way to
isolate nuclei so we've used this method
where we couple nuclei sorting to attack
seek and there's some nice work from
Roger deal where he's been using an
another method for a nuclear isolation
where then you can apply a taxi so what
we've all learned at the community is
you need pure nuclei and you need
separate from those organelle or genomes
and this benchmark really nicely to what
was the gold standard accessibility data
at the time in Arabidopsis this DNA CTA
seek data from Christine Quietus lab and
and at the time we could show that we
could again use this on 500 nuclei and
of course this again being used for
single cell nuclei now so it's not that
exciting but it also worked on you know
sorting nuclear localized GFP lines that
were available and so this is this is
useful because there's a lot of
pre-existing plant lines that are out
there in the community because they
study a very specific cell types were
they can sort if they choose to that
specific cell line to profile the
accessible chromatin environment so the
assay was working and we turned to
applying it to other genomes and I won't
go into the history of why we started
doing this but what I'll tell you is a
light bulb turned on and that's mostly
because and I'll show you how attack
seek helped us focus all these other
epic epigenome datasets on on really
pinpointing these distal regulatory
elements so today I'm going to show you
data some RNA data again it's mostly
focused on looking at that attack thief
data we have we do have some whole
genome bisulfite sequencing data look at
DNA methylation turns out this is
another part that my lab studies I'm not
gonna talk about it all today but it's
kind of interesting that the regions
that are accessible have
essentially they're depleted for DNA
methylation so now I feel like I'm
studying the entire genome there's a
whole variety of different chromatin
modifications that we've also profiled
don't worry about understanding and
having to understand what each of these
it does I'll point it out if it's
important and I'll show you at the later
on how we've been using some more
functional assays to really test assign
these regions to their target genes and
then test for your activity and so this
is sort of the landscape of the
epigenome when you focus in on genes and
what I'll tell you is really nothing
surprised us here everything that we
already learned about that the chromatin
modification landscape at genes it was
was predicted based on what we already
knew from Arabidopsis and turns out
transcription in eukaryotes is a pretty
highly conserved process of course there
are some variations and so what you're
seeing here is that the genes are ranked
from their highest expressed gene to the
lowest expressed gene and the red line
up here shows sort of a meta profile for
the bottom 20% of express genes and the
blue line shows the meta profile for the
for the top 20% of express genes so you
see a lot of high methylation here in
the low expressed genes and then another
group of low expressed genes have h3k27
trimethylation this is a modification
imparted by the polycomb-group proteins
involved in repression and then you can
find other activating mark or marks
associated activation so k4
trimethylation and you can see k36
trimethylation gene body so this just
shows you again the data is of high
quality but again everything that that
we observed here was what we have
predicted based on our previous work in
a rabid offices I'll show you how the
data became become really useful we
start trying to study the chromatin
environment of these these these distal
accessible chromatin regions so having
worked on a rabid offices for a large
number of many years this concept that
this still regulation was foreign and of
course it didn't exist and they were
there of course well known examples
amazed but those were those were those
were you know nuances they were they
weren't really real or they were just
you know they became real really quickly
so here's one of them that was very real
this is the tb1 QTL in maize and it and
it's important because it's one of these
major QTL that leads from this sort of
bushy
a phenotype to this more upright statue
rights as important for inflorescence
architecture and many people including a
lot of work led by John Dolby's group
had really through brute force fine
mapping identified about at 11 KB region
that was 70 KB away from the coding
sequence the tb1 coding sequence so it
was a bona fide distal regulatory
element right that was again cloned
through this brute-force mapping and
what they found was that if you look in
that 11 KB region that's the energetic
space is there is a region that it has
very low nucleotide diversity compared
to nearby regions and turns out this
actually overlaps sees these transpose
what elements and when they took the
sequences underneath this region with
with very high sequence constraint and
they fused it to reporter they could
show that it can lead to activation of
that reporter right even showing
functionally that these sequences even
though they're 70 kPa can activate that
reporter gene so it's a really classic
example of obvious distal of the
potential for distal regulation in plant
genomes and so when we generated our
data first place we looked at was sort
of these handful of important loci that
have been characterized over the years
it's really about four or five of them
and so this is the TV one locus so TV
one you can see is located all the way
over here this is the coding sequence
here's the tract of DNA methylation
here's a track of h3k27 trimethylation
just remember again this is involved in
transcriptional repression and then
here's the attack seek date and this is
what really opened our eyes this is a
really clean type of data that we're not
used to working with such clean data and
you can find this really nice sharp peak
they're typically two to four hundred
base pairs in size of accessibility
right and when we saw this we were
really excited we thought wow
only you know john Dobies group had
access to this while they're trying to
map the genetic basis for this QTL this
could have helped speed up this process
and so we we dig back through the paper
and we look at the region that they
showed was important for activating that
reporter and then we were really
disappointed because we found that this
region is actually not in that QTL and
then we realized because we're not
developmental biologists that TV one
isn't expressed in the leaves and you
want to predict it to be there and so we
repeated the experiment in the tissue
that's important
forty b1 control of inflorescence
architecture and that's in the young
developing amazing in fluorescence and
so we did that experiment in the ear and
what we saw we thought was quite
remarkable so this most distal region of
accessibility is lost and now you see
these two new regions emerged and they
perfectly localized to this region that
has been genetically characterized and
functionally characterized to be
important for sort of distally
activating t b1
what you also see happen is the promoter
now opens up and now you can see an
abundance of RNA transcripts coming from
this this gene right so this was
exciting to us because I thought show
you this isn't just and do it nuanced
example it turns out these are really
prevalent not just in maze but but the
plants with large genomes and so I'm
gonna refer to these as distal
accessible regions actually I'm gonna
almost primarily focus on these distal
regions today there's there's
essentially a continuum right I'll show
you examples where they start here at
over the transcriptional start site and
then again they basically can get pushed
out over time we can speculate about how
that might happen but I want to focus on
these distal ones because we've always
sort of guessed this plant biologists
the sequences must be there within a
couple KB we'll take that see if we can
rescue or make reporters but but but you
know and that was a basically guest work
right but now we can pinpoint these
regions we think this is not an isolated
example too so here's another example of
a recent qto that was again cloned by
john doe being in collaboration with
funk shawn flap studying this flowering
time adaptation locust and what they
found for g waswas there's this region
of really high linkage disequilibrium
that occurred about fifty kilobases away
from this gene c CT nine and this is
where you have the strongest signal for
that that g wast and then we quickly
looked in art and our data and sure
enough right underneath that region you
find this region of accessibility again
i think you know i really believe that
these data are going to facilitate the
identification of QTL just like the
annotation of genes does so this is not
rare and you're and this is you know no
surprise to this crowd there's been some
really great work from ed buckler's
group and collaboration with hank bass
where
they have showed that you know even
though these regions of chromatin
accessibility are minor fraction of the
maze genome they contain a tremendous
amount of the the heritable phenotypic
variation underlying these complex
traits and so we really now are excited
about further discovering these elements
not just in maize but but in other plant
genomes but I'll continue to focus on
maize just for today first part of this
talk so we started to characterize these
right what what's their distribution to
their nearest gene and as you might
expect that the majority of these
regions are located with you know very
close to that initial or that you know
transcriptional start site but if you
look closely you can see there's another
bimodal peak this other peak hits this
peak at about 30 to kilobases all right
this is can you think about the
Arabidopsis genome you can fit eight or
nine genes in 32 kilobases right so this
is there are many of these thousands of
these in fact by our calculations
there's about a third of these
successful regions we'd consider distal
right there distant or far away from
that gene we can look at those energetic
accessible regions and we can look at
their GC content and find that it's it's
very distinct from other nearby
energetic sequences right which is
important for for nucleus own
positioning and likely harboring these
transcription factor binding sites so
they're they're distinct from other
energetic sequences and then I won't go
into details today but we have a nice
collaboration with andre agassi lab but
at Rutgers in between our labs we've
we've been able to profile DNA protein
interactions for almost 50 transcription
factors now in maize and we can
seemingly look specifically at these
distal regions this is just showing
enrichment at the at the this is the TSS
the same thing happens at these distal
regions you can find enrichment for
binding so what I'm trying to take you
down a path where we can find these
accessible regions and I want to try to
convince you that they're actually
functional and so this is part of that
in that they can be bound by
transcription factors so another I mean
talk to Idi and others you know not the
molecular biologists this is function
right you look at genetic diversity and
evolutionary genetics and so what we can
do is we can take those accessible
chromatin regions that exist at our
distal and we can look at again at their
nucleotide diversity using sort of the
the mazed
diversity sequence data that's out there
and see that again at these regions of
excess
ability they have their sequence
constrained compared to nearby sequences
and we can take some other data from
this a gy6
sort of a catalog that the Jason Walsh
did while he was in Ed's lab and show
that there's an enrichment for jiwa
signal coming from these regions of
distal chromatin accessibility again
indicating they're functional I think
this is remarkable because this is just
a accessible data from leaf right into a
single tissue where these G wast data
come from a whole range of phenotypes so
I think this signal gets stronger and
stronger as we resolve the number of
cell types that we can profile
accessible chromatin from and then in a
really nice collaboration with an
ongoing collaboration with Katherine
Maynard where her who's here that the
audience will use the data from the
rather the recent eqtl study by by Ed
flab and we could show that there's a
really strong enrichment for these eqtl
again in these distal accessible
chromatin region again indicating these
regions are functionally important all
right so that's the evolutionary
genetics now I told you earlier when we
use chromatin modification data we
didn't really learn anything when we
looked at gene space but we started to
characterize these distal chromatin
accessible regions based on their local
chromatin modification environment and I
think it becomes quite revealing and
predictive likely of what's happening at
these regions so all of the next we
basically found there's four different
chromatin environments and so all of
these in the next four classes I'm going
to show you they all have accessibility
so this is just showing accessibility
again these are distal accessible
regions so they're far away from nearby
genes so this particular class has a set
elation so it doesn't matter which type
of a satellite we look at you see
enrichment of histone acetylation
flanking this is important flanking both
sides of the chromatin accessible region
not one side both sides right and so
this is you would predict then these
will be involved in transcriptional
activation right the other class we find
are these ones that are flanked by h3k27
trimethylation so you see that here
again they're accessible
there's h3k27 trimethylation and the
other modifications are depleted and you
know there's you know there's a lot of
great literature we understand very well
about how this modification and its
function in sort of repressing gene
activity
so the prediction is these are distal
regions that are imparting repression on
their target genes
the next group we found through a spit
for a loop because if you look at it it
looks just like a transcribe gene and
that's why we call you the transcribe
group right there is basically but
enrichment for k4 trimethylation there's
h3 k36 trimethylation in the body of
that region and you see RNAs
actually coming from from these regions
and they look like genes because we
actually think they're genes they're uh
nana Teta genes in this reference genome
or their unattended long non-coding rnas
all right so even though we found them
as distal accessible region because
using annotation they were far away from
the nearest gene we just think that
they're not annotated so I'm not going
to talk about these any further it's not
- obviously if I own an annotated gene
it's not that interesting but but it's
not to minimize that some of these could
be important for control of nearby genes
they've learned long non-coding RNAs but
these aren't sort of this classic like
the first two groups I showed you we
think this is a bit of an annotation
artifact and the last group we found
were just completely unmodified so
there's plenty you know these are
accessible regions again they're distal
from genes and there's no modification
around them and these are actually the
most abundant of all the classes that
we've identified so when you look at
these four genes we can again start to
try to functionally characterize them
using gene ontology and what you see is
again we're a little bit of a guessing
game because we know there's a region of
accessibility but we don't know if it's
associating with a gene on the left or
the right or if he skips a gene so what
we did we took genes on both sides we
use this in gene ontology and what we
found for the acetylenic group are terms
of what you would respect right these
are response and your stimuli
inconsistent with activation that k-27
trimethylation group and this unmodified
group all these terms associated with
transcription and regulation DNA binding
right this is again what we'd expect a
lot of transcription factors and plants
are controlled in a very specific manner
as my silencing or either a silencing of
k-27 or removal of k-27 trimethylation
and then like I told you earlier this
transcribed group which I'm not going to
focus on so much when we use geo and
actually come back with no terms I
didn't think that was possible to get no
terms but you can get no terms from geo
so whether we've struggled is actually
with then
taking these ACRs because we have these
predictions the Isetta layer should be
associated with transcribed genes that
k-27 should be is associated with
repressed genes and we try every which
way we never could find his clear
associations with their nearest genes
again we're a little bit of a guessing
game we don't know if it's the left or
right gene and so I'll come back to this
point later on but this basically
reveals two major challenges that we
faced at the time one is we need to find
a way to associate these distal
accessible chromatin regions with their
target gene all right and then the other
is just because they're accessible
doesn't mean they're functional right so
the way we got at assigning these distal
accessible chromatin regions to their
nearby gene was using these proximity
ligation methods so you might have heard
of hi-c we're that we're using a variant
called hide ship and I'll explain how
those work and then I'll show you in a
few more slides how we've been able to
functionally demonstrate at least some
of these accessible regions how the
capacity to activate a reporter gene
using this method called star seek so
typically what we do in the plant
community I've seen many of us in
regards will work on you think you find
an important regulatory element you
stick it up upstream a reporter and you
ask can it activate that reporter
expression so I'm going to show you a
method that we've adopted again from
first developed for use in Drosophila
and how we've applied that to the maize
genome so assigning genes and these
distal accessible chromatin regions to
their target genes you know we're all
guilty of looking at genome browsers and
in thinking the genomes you know there's
really long two-dimensional space but we
know it's highly compartmentalized and
organized in the nucleus and so you can
you know if looking at genome browser
these are supposed to be nucleosomes you
can find regions of accessibility and
then maybe there's a region of distal
accessibility over here but in reality
what happens in three-dimensional space
is there's a loop that's forming here
right and this can be a mediated in part
by sequence specific factors among
others and so you can map these sort of
three-dimensional interactions using
proximity ligation methods like hi-c and
so what you can do is you can freeze
essentially in time these this chromatin
sort of a compartmentalization you
digest the genome and you rely gate and
sometimes your we rely gate sequences
that were distal or basically far were
far apart in two-dimensional space but
it tells you they must have been close
together in three-dimensional space so
for example we can map the interactions
that occur here that really are are in
two-dimensional space very far away now
the challenge with high C is you need
really deep pockets especially for you
know animes genomes not you know that
different from the human or mouse genome
but you know something that really has I
think plagued a plant community for a
long time which is changing rapidly will
change very rapidly is these were always
mixing cell types right we're to move
taken like a whole leaf I always say
it's like chopping off your arm and
grinding it up it's like there's so much
complexity in these tissues you know
above ground aerial parts you'll see in
methods right and so you're not just
doing I see for a cell line you know
your signal is completely diluted by all
those different sort of hi-c patterns
that would emerge in different cell
types so this just really wasn't
something that we could do and I say we
couldn't do of course we did it and we
realized we shouldn't do it so I'll show
you the next slide how that works but
what we realize to speak because amount
of sequencing that would have been
required to really do this experiment
the right way that we used a modified
version again we're really fortunate
because there is some nice methodology
where we used a variant called hi chip
from Howard Chang and and again we'll
Greenleaf lab from Stanford University
which basically allows you to capture
these chromatin confirmations right
using proximity ligation and then you
follow up this experiment with amino
precipitation so we're using antibodies
against Trent that you can use against
transcription factors we're using
antibodies against again specific
histone modifications so using this
method or only finding interactions that
occur where these histone modifications
are found in the G and if you remember
these many of these regions that are
accessible and and distal to genes they
have specific chromatin modification
environment around them so this allows
us to try to test what genes they
interact with now this doesn't resolve
the cell type issue right but what it
does allow us to do somewhat
superficially is at least separate the
transcribed active genes from the
repressed genes so maybe it simplifies
that state to the express state and the
repressed State there's one idea and
because of that because of you know
separating expression states and then
and then sort of the trim down version
not looking at all pairwise interactions
in the genome require many few fewer
sequencing reads so
becomes achievable to test unlimited
sample numbers so this is what our hi-c
data looked like at the time again this
is a contact probability map and so what
you're looking at is this blue is this
background color and here's a TV one
gene when this arrow is located and then
what you see here is that that distal
accessible region that 70 KB away and
when you can generally see any time you
see heat on this map what you're
basically seeing is that there's
basically a large interaction occurring
here between this whole domain it was
basically folding up on itself but when
we again separated this domain based on
the repressed allele versus what could
be seen as the active allele you see a
very different picture when we use hi
chip right so now this becomes very
apparent and there's big X you see here
it's just a region where we can't map
the DNA it's highly repetitive genome so
that's why it looks like it's background
but you can say very clearly that if you
wanted to try to assign this just so
accessible accessible region to the gene
over here it's very clear it's actually
interacting with the tb1 gene right so
this is allowing us now to assign these
genes to there are these successful
regions to their target genes and I like
to show this not in one example we
should be preface this we actually don't
know if this is causal but it's it's
been it's being tested but it's a nice
example because people like Sarah hake
and Dave Jackson had worked on this for
many years among others you know they'll
tell you we've never been able to rescue
the mutant phenotype using endogenous
sequences right we're missing something
in dates like we've even used 50
kilobases upstream doesn't work and so
what you look if you look at the knot in
one locus again hi chip you kind of
squint your eyes and see something with
high once I see your squint your eyes
with high chip it's it's so clear so
again here's the knotted one coding
sequence and here's this distal
accessible region it's 91 KB away from
not at one and you see this beautiful
loop that's forming here right it's just
perfectly interacting with the knot in
one locus and so now what what people in
that field can do is they can go in here
and use loss of function studies all
right this becomes a candidate for I
talked about earlier for for targeting
with CRISPR mutagenesis right edit this
region see if you can then create that
mutant phenotype or modulate WN
phenotype
secondly you can do gain-of-function
assays you can take these sequences out
here and start to basically move them
next to these you know the endogenous
gene to see if you can actually rescue
you know time so this is how we think
these data will be useful so bill
reaching the lab he's the one that got
high chip up and running and he started
looking through the the analysis and and
in any of these sort of any time you're
running genome-wide analysis you're
basically looking at confidence right
you're looking at confidence for
interaction for peak calling and what
Bill noticed I thought was actually
quite quite remarkable
he discovered that what we already knew
is that genes themselves end up being
hubs for lots of promet interaction so
he puts these anchors here because you
see a lot of interactions extending from
these genes but if you factor in the
strength of the interaction right this
is based on a statistical test and the
strength here is is increasing as you go
down here what he notices that strength
of interaction was highly predictive for
what are likely sequence specific a loop
interactions so here you have the tv1
region that you've seen a few times
here's a tip on coding sequence there
are multiple interactions that occur
with tb1
but notice this one here with it with
the basically the strongest p-value it
perfectly localized this to that region
is known to associate with the tb1 locus
and he could show this again in
collaboration with Katherine and Ed slab
using their eqtl data again looking at
some of those strongest each Yuki Yuki
looking at some of the eqtl when you
rank at these chromatin reactions based
on their p-value it's very very
indicative likely of sequence specific
interactions versus sort of localized
chromatin interactions out of curve just
because they're in the similar
neighborhood so bill could go on and
show especially for look for the k4
trimethylation data this was especially
true overall there's a significant
proportion of these eqtl distal
accessible region gene pairs that are
highly enriched and when you factor in
this strength of interaction look at the
eqtl loops compared to all the loops
right you factor and look at their
p-values they're really strong right so
that I think this is really an important
and we haven't seen this before in any
species where you factor in the strength
of this interaction that actually could
be predicted for a true sort of sequence
specific interaction versus these sort
of localized chromatin contacts that can
happen and remember I told you that when
we try to associate you know
it's predictive these regions of
chromatin accessibility with histone
acetylation you would predict will be
associated with a transcribed gene and
vice-versa for K 27 try and that never
worked for us and again we could even
use our loop data here and we know what
gene associate with now and it's still
really noisy but when we factor in again
the strength of the interaction here
using the hi chip data now it becomes
much clearer right you see that the K 27
regions are very lowly expressed in the
case at elation regions are very highly
expressed and so it finally started to
resolve those expectations that we had
from the beginning but it only happened
when we factored in the strength of
these interactions and so basically what
you see happening is and this isn't to
offend any of the maize researchers here
and in the audience but what it feels
like it looks like it's probably
happening is the maize genome was
essentially transformed itself into the
Arabidopsis genome right so if you look
at the DNA methylation tract what you
see here is all this methylation and
what you'll notice is what regions are
unmethylated either have a transcribed
unit there or you have these accessible
chromatin regions and then what you're
seeing here are in the black boxes are
edges of loops right and you can see
those loops are highly enriched in these
regions that are not DNA methylated
right and so what Bill hypothesized
which I think you spot on is that what
you're seeing happening here is you're
looping out all this sort of large
domains of h3k9 methylation and DNA
methylation it doesn't contain any any
or any regulatory information and you're
again you're sort of transforming that
large maize genome into this little trim
or have adopts this genome here just as
an analogy and so you can now place
those sequence elements nearby their
target genes and so in the high shift
data what you often see is again these
sort of localized chromatin interactions
and and they're real but do they just
happen because they're near by each
other now right first is what we
hypothesize when you factor in strength
of that interaction we hypothesize that
these are mediated by sequence specific
factors right off likely transcription
factors and there are likely others
there's no ctcf in plants but we're
thinking along these lines okay so we
can identify these distal accessible
chromatin regions we can with
high confidence to this to a subset of
them assign them to their target genes
but are they functional and one way
we've tried to get at that is to adopt
again this methodology that was first
sort of applied to Drosophila to plant
genomes and so this is a method called
star seek developed by Alec stars group
and what they learned was they basically
took advantage of the gene model right
we think of this as enhancer promoter
expression and of course as I've showed
you throughout this presentation we know
that these enhancers can occur
downstream and then through 3d
conformational loop around and interact
with that core promoter to drive
expression so they took advantage of
this principle and what they did was
they chopped up the entire Drosophila
genome into two to three hundred base
pair fragments and they cloned it into
this system where instead of now having
a node enhancer here or when you're
testing you're just testing all possible
fragments in the in the Drosophila
genome you take this library of clones
that you've created you transfect that
into these two Southwest two cells you
incubate give it time to induce
transcription and any time a sequence in
here is able to interact with the core
promoter to drive expression it ends up
transcribing itself and then you can
specifically capture these mRNAs that
come from from this this this vector you
sequence the RNA and you can at least
find element that can drive expression
all right so what be useful for finding
those that can get can lead to
repression but it can find those that
can activate expression in the system so
again this is a again work from Bill
where he worked almost two years on this
and it's working like a charm now so
what he did was he took this library of
ataxic fragments so I'm gonna show you
two slides two different results in the
next slide one of them is a pilot where
we just took the back loan where the T V
one locus resides because I get costs
involved here we could chop it up into
smaller fragments and test it and then
what we did was because we couldn't
afford we didn't think of the time
afford to do the whole maze
transcriptome the whole maze genome we
just hypothesized that well the we're
testing these successful regions for
activities so we we devised a way to
clone in an attack seek library into the
star vector so where we were trying to
test us specific reads it turns out we
tested pretty much the whole genome
but so you know there's always
background in any library you make it so
we were able to see that so we have a
very similar setup there's a minimal 35s
promoter there's a small open reading
frame space there again we clone in the
fragments here and as this poly a tail
that allows you to capture it and Bill
spent hours and many ninth growing
leaders and leaders of e.coli
to generate a really diverse library
that he then had to get into efficiently
into maze proto class and he was able
this is just a control showing GFP but
he was able to achieve over 60%
transformation efficiency of these maze
protoplasts and from that were able to
serve eighth an essentially 15 million
independent events and what's great
about this assay is there's not costly
for sequencing the sequencing is cheap
the costs in is in the production of all
these libraries and so at the end what
you do is your sequence RNA and DNA and
you compare how much RNA do you recover
versus how much input DNA did you start
with and that's the measure of activity
and so again here's the experiment we
did in the back clone so this is again
the TV one locus here's the coding
sequence you hear these distal
accessible regions here's well methinks
the repressor this is one we think it's
involved in activation and what you see
very nicely is that there's this
background sort of DNA level you recover
and then you see activity and you can
see here there's reporter activity
coming perfectly from this region that
John Doe is groups showed that activate
that reporter right you also see
activity coming from the that in sort of
promoter region as well so this assay is
working we can apply this genome-wide
and what we see is we basically again
separated those two successful regions
based on their chromatin environment so
I know I kind of sort of tossed this
group aside earlier but it's a little
convenient now because even though we
don't think they're distal accessible
regions you know that their genes and
what you see is this is a ratio of DNA
to RNA so anything that pops off on the
x-axis is showing a transcriptional
activity and so what you see for the
transcribed group is these elements
report the most activity which again you
might predict because they're actually
transcribed genes but what also happens
as you see this happen these distal
accessible region on these are not genes
these are these are just so accessible
regions many of these show reporter
activity and then the unmodified and
k-27 group have very few the very
there's very low evidence that they show
activity and this actually fits with
with their proposed functions and so we
think we've shown at least for a subset
of these regions that they actually can
lead to transcriptional activation now
keep in mind any time we do that in a
state like this you're testing the
interaction of that sequence with that
minimal promoter and so we have a nice
collaboration with Christina quite just
where they're trying to innovate and
develop a whole range of novel minimal
motors to basically you know sample
different you know different different
elements that can interact with those
promoters to drive expression okay again
what's important just to come back when
you think about that sort of definition
of what are these these regulatory
elements they can be you know sort of
upstream downstream any orientation what
we didn't realize at the time that was
pointed out to us was you know the way
we cloned in this library is unbiased it
goes in both ways and so we were able to
test of all those regions that showed
activation did it happen did it matter
the orientation of the insert turns out
it doesn't over 90 percent of these
regions showed activity from both
orientations right and didn't matter
whether or not they were upstream or
downstream with their target genes so we
really believe these are bonafide
sort of enhancer sequences okay so I'm
gonna stop talking about maize and just
transition to some of the comparative
workmen we've started to do and looking
at other plant species and maize really
was the one we drilled down deep on and
now we're trying to go wide in many
other grass species but we also try to
be representative horse I said
representative but most of our genomes
are from crops because it's it's already
a biased group but we performed a taxi
can all these other other species we try
to focus on leaf sample to keep it
somewhat similar appreciate there are
really differences in biology between
leaves of different species but I think
there's some clear take-home points here
so one of them is you can see that the
total amount of accessible space that's
here in these genomes is actually quite
similar regardless of genome size so
what you're seeing here is these species
are ordered based on their genome size
so rabid OPS's has about 100 mega base
genome barley has about a 5 gig base
genome and regardless of the genome size
the amount of sequence underlying
accessible chromatin is about the same
and if you plot that as a proportion of
the genome of course what you
see is the bigger the genome the lower
proportion of the genome they represent
and and what I think this is
communicating to us is that these are
limited in genome they're not repeat
they're not proliferating right there
just like genes in many ways there's
there because they're associated with
genes again I showed you earlier in
maize that there's really despite
modality up there their location to
their nearest gene they're either right
out over the transcriptional start site
or you start to see this other peak that
occurs further away from the gene and
when we rank again these genes based on
their genome size you see for example
duckweed a rabid OPS's most of their
regions are right next to the
transcriptional start side and if some
of them you know get to a KB away but
when you look at these bigger genomes
like asparagus and barley and maize you
see many more further away it correlates
very highly with with the size of the
genome with bigger genomes these regions
can be found further away from life to
their target genes and you can see that
based on this classification system we
use do they overlap the gene are there
proximal to the gene or they distal you
can see that again with increasing
genome size they just you know move
further and further away from the gene
and we can all speculate later about how
that happens what we can we can talk
about it if there's interest so we also
perform the same chip experiments
looking at sort of key chromatin
modifications and all of these species
and just like before we have this
transcribed group so this transcribed
group the top row has k4 trimethylation
a histone acetylation and body k 36
that's what a transcribed locus looks
like so it no surprise here are the
accessible regions that are oh the TSS
have those chromatin modifications but
again as you look at the distance so
these become proximal it's moving
further away from the gene and I get to
these distal regions right there they're
they're far away from the gene what you
see happen is you lose association with
a chromatin modifications that are
associated with transcription and what
you get a fine are these three main
groups you find this unmodified group
which by far and away it's the largest
classification and all of them and then
you find this k-27 tri methylation and
histone acetyltransferase
we can take gene ontology like we did
for maize and what happens is whenever
you look this is all there's a lot going
on here but long long story short is if
you look at that k-27 group and
that unmodified group and every species
we look at you do gene ontology you
always find DNA binding or regulation
right
okay and we think these are critical
regions that are distal regulating a you
know key transcription factor is
important or for development or a
response to the environment again just
like in maize we can look at all the
sequence diversity panels that are out
there for all of these species we can
look at these distal accessible
chromatin regions and what we can see is
just like in maize they're depleted for
sequence variation compared to nearby
sequences again indicating some level of
sequence constraint and then we can try
this is where we fell miserably because
we're not very good evolutionary
geneticist but we try you know we can we
can take advantage for example for
example these five related grasses right
and you can see the region of synteny
here and there's this region of
accessibility that's shared amongst all
of them and that red box is showing you
a sequence that is highly conserved
right so you can start to think about
the sort of the role of conserved
non-coding sequences that help drive
these accessible chromatin regions and
what we can see is that when we look at
these accessible chromatin regions so we
identify conserved non-coding sequences
between all of these with all the dicots
and then separately all the monocots and
what we can see very very nicely is
there's they're highly enriched for
these conserved non-coding sequences
right in these distal accessible
chromatin regions and again when you
look at the chromatin environment these
four different chromatin classes here
you can see that you know even between
distantly related species these CNSs
have these conserved
chromatin modifications so here's a
class at all have k-27 between all
species right here's a class that that's
transcribed and so forth so there are
sequence determinants that are leading
to the reader to them being accessible
but they're highly conserved in some
instances here's an example I like to
show because I think it starts to help
you think about how the landscape of
chromatin accessibility can form in
these species so again this is a
reasonable synteny between maize and
rice
I'm sorry sorghum and what you can see
here is there's a region of
accessibility at the basically right at
the transcriptional start site for this
sorghum locus if you take the sequence
underneath this and blast it to the
maize genome
you get one hit and it Maps perfectly to
the successful chromatin region that's
here that's now 100 KB away from its
likely target gene right so you can
start to think what happened right
did it transpose on sort of snuggle in
there and just create space and then of
course over time it's easier to push it
further away that's one idea and then of
course it's it's very hard to have such
acute deletions that delete just this
region but not the successful chromatin
region so you can start to think about
how these involve of course another way
in which that can happen is well the way
in which you push it away is because
there's transposon content right so we
compare these instances between maize
and and sorghum what we find is the
distance between the between their
themselves in their target gene is
highly correlated with the transposon
content really not a surprise you think
that's what's in this energetic space
but it helps you think about transposons
can shape the accessibility landscape
and genomes and at the same time we can
start to think about that I always
forget to say this
both the TB one example and the CCT 9
example are accessible regions that are
embedded in transposons right and so
there are examples where transposons can
Harbor these regions it can create new
regulation and so transposon biologists
sometimes don't like to show if I show
this to Nathan Springer and say oh if we
look on average right accessible regions
that are fully embedded within
transposons are depleted in the genome
but he'll say but they're there and he's
right right we wouldn't expect every
transposon to have accessible chromatin
and they clearly don't because they're
depleted compared to what you expect by
random chance but they are there and
when we categorize all these different
species based on their transposon
content what we find is that certain
classes of these DNA transposons or
highly enriched in these accessible
chromatin regions and there's cedric and
others will tell you it's it's a bit of
a circular argument when you're looking
at these DNA transposon it's because
remember we're using a transpose days to
actually define these regions but you'll
also find certain classes of retros also
that can have can have access flow
regions so we're trying to focus in on
this more with with incorporation with
Nathan Springer so I'm just going to
wrap up I hope I've convinced you that
there are and distal regulation implant
genomes actually is occur it's not a
nuance I think it's going to be far more
common especially think about all the
existing cutie
studies that are out there I really help
think and G wash experiments I think
this will help facilitate the
identification of the causal variants if
that's of interest we can use chromatin
modification and accessibility to
uncover and make predictions about how
that element might interact with the
gene and again we can use chromatin
contact interactions and the strength of
that interaction to maybe predict again
the sequence specific interactions
versus georgeous localized chromatin
interactions that occur because you're
in similar subdomains of the chromatin I
mean what we're doing now is we're
basically continuing this path of
creating maps across development and
time and species to really characterize
and help create a compendium really of
these sort of a putative regulatory
elements in plant genomes and we're
trying to follow up with some more
functional and some variations of star
seek that we're trying to Ithaca we've
been doing some single-cell attack seek
which is working really nicely and of
course what we'd like to do DNA back to
that first slide is start functionally
testing these right so this is a little
bit harder from my lab because we don't
you know there aren't many in
Arabidopsis and they're not the ones
that are interesting to study but we
talked about creating lilyc variation
again at these regions if there's
sociated with jeans with no function be
fun to start modifying them which we're
trying to do to see if you can induce
that variation again I'm rapidly alright
so I'm gonna wrap up again think I think
you know this you know the great work
from Bill and again there's a really
strong collaboration I have with a
neighboring lab with Xiang Yu Xiang
again he could be presenting the same
data to you and then the people my lab
that participated in again staff who
developed the ataxic methodology for
application of plants and then all four
people in my lab drove the data analysis
and again we've had a lot of support
from from collaborators some of them
that are here and again none of this was
not is possible without the support of
NSF and the plant Genome Research
Program and with that I'll stop and
thank you for time and take any
questions if you have any
[Applause]
you call on people and then repeat the
question I'd have asked Bob to go ahead
and and mediate the questions here so
raise your hand when you're ready with a
question and he'll know calling you yeah
Paul
so I posted about these four categories
of Peaks the ones that have history of
civil Asian 87th appellation transcribed
or modified histones a wondering if they
have any differences in consultation
among those categories other species and
also whether there are any transcription
factor motifs that are enriched those
that might also be preserved yeah so the
question is when we look at those
categories of for transcript of the
categories are these distal accessible
chromatin regions based on their local
chromatin vironment how conserved are
they or certain classes more conserved
than others and are they enriched for
transcription factor binding motif so
I'll answer a second part first because
the transcription factor binding motif
is interesting so we can see that at
least in maize these regions are highly
enriched in transcription factor binding
motifs but but there are some some
implants polycomb in many cases it's
recruited to targets based on
interactions of transcription factors
and there's some well-known examples
that maybe our core recruiters and so we
look specifically at those and we can
find some of those motifs underlying in
those regions right so we think again
the major a major mode for polycomb
repression plants is actually TF
recruitment of polycomb based on those
elements to look at the conservation
this is hard right so even though I
showed you is conserved non-coding
sequences we've taken thousands of
thousand elements we're down about five
hundred all right so the numbers become
really low really quickly and I'll tell
you I know there's some experts here
this is not something our lab is really
good at we're using pretty primitive
sequence alignment methods and it's any
you that studied energetic you know
sequence it turns out were fast and so
we can see you know all the time we can
see these since antenna Cree jhin's
there's there's clear reasons of
accessibility upstream both and you look
at the sequence underneath them and it's
you know to take a six base pair motif
to maintain it so this is where we've
really struggled on maybe Katherine has
ways to solve that problem
we modify the they don't okay so three
certainly have three questions one is
how does map ability affect the analysis
and it's a great question it's something
that you just can't avoid right
especially not highly repetitive genome
I will tell you that we always map the
data two ways we always do sort of
unique sort of very conservative mapping
and that's typically what we use in
publications but we can always we always
allow reads to map everywhere too
especially for things like the element
of TV one I didn't show you it's
actually found in three different
locations in general it's not I don't
think that big of an issue because
repetitive regions are typically
silenced and heterochromatin is very
quickly in plant genomes and so these
regions of accessibility are not found
in those regions or anti-correlated so
you know not to not trivialize it we
mature we miss some but I don't think
it's a major concern this may give you a
heart attack but we actually use paradin
35 base pair reads because we don't pick
up many more reads when we use pair than
150 right so we are always trying to
save money and push the number of
samples we can we can use the second
question was how maybe how often these
turn over again we this is not something
we've really addressed yet when we start
to use these you know we're talking
about you know 12 million years of
evolution you know it's still far apart
right and so we can always find examples
but we get 200
sometimes dozens between species so we
don't ever make too many inferences
about what's happening
we don't think I have the power to do
that how many well maybe yeah so so if
we you know the question is how many
accessible chromatin regions are there
per gene and I would say on average one
all right one to two right the teepee
one example is not common we're in two
different tissues you see c3 plus the
promoter for Regions right that's not
that common right if you look at the
numbers these k-27 group in the chaos at
elation group come about a thousand
right and I didn't show you the data but
if you look between different tissues
for example root or ear and leave about
thirteen or fourteen percent or
differential right so you know again
this which ingen differential we're
grinding up really complex tissues but I
think this will change with a single
cell data and the unmodified group I
mean we don't know but the CHEO terms
are quite intriguing right and so one
thing we have shown it's not it's never
all or none but we look at those
different tissues and we see in one
tissue is unmodified and then all of a
sudden an ear does it become modified
alright we can see evidence of that so
it's unmodified at that time but again
we're looking at really limited numbers
yeah and there's lots of caveats with
our starsia means I think it's amazing
but there are caveats right I mean you
know show you the TV one example but I'd
showed you TV ones not expressed in
leaves and well we're losing leaf
protoplasts why is it active well you've
taken something put it on a plasma
you've removed it from his native
chromatin environment we can see that
over and over in our data so I mean it's
great it's it helps push the field
forward but there are some biological
limitations of the assay so I think
there are many more as well
last point John yeah yeah we do not see
anything like that right and so again I
don't know how much of it is because
there are you know there are peaks that
are being drowned out because you know I
work do a lot of work on bisulfite
sequencing but you were looking at
dominant cell type when you have an
Excel populations so that might be
resolved in looking at single cell
attacks of data but we haven't really
incorporated the high chip data to test
for that I will tell you from our high
chip data what we can see is that
actually making the guests at the
accessible regions upstream is a pretty
good guess eighty percent of time based
on a high chip data that's right I can
tell you that that's how I use the data
but yeah the number at least at this
point so we've done some environmental
treatments as well and really early on
and then we realized you know we always
always call us the squinty eye test in
laboratory looking at data I'm like oh
there's kind of something there but
again I think it's this issue of it's
happening in some cell types not others
and then we we put on the shelves and
focused on you know function but I think
we're getting back to those now
especially again with with with how well
a single cell taxi works in plants as
well it's early days I think
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu